so your suggestion is if people are
trying to learn something they should be
doing it well i think that would be a
pretty good start honestly like
it's amazing to me that you know if you
look back in history there's just this
long chain of people learning by
apprenticeship
by you know being introduced to a
community that practices something
and this whole idea of you know
universal education where you remove
people from the environment and get them
to sit in desks and you lecture at them
for for dozens of years is a relatively
new invention
and i don't want to suggest that it
doesn't have a place i mean i i've taken
so many online courses now i'm
definitely a fan so i'm not
criticizing from perspective that no one
should ever go to school but just
that it is somewhat unnatural in that
way that you know the way that we learn
how to do most things is by doing it by
some sort of form of apprenticeship by
being kind of slowly brought into the
community that practices it and so
you know i think that that's something
that's worth considering especially if
you feel like school just doesn't fit
your personality or what you're
interested in